joining me today is the author of the
orphan X novels a comic book writer
whose work includes Batman Wolverine and
The Punisher and a guy trying to save
the Democrats Greg Hurwitz how's it
going it's good to see you oh that's the
scariest one you can write all the
thriller novels you watch worse than the
rogues gallery it's worse than any
Batman villain or evil fury I've ever
heard trying to save the Democrats but
you're trying we're gonna get to that in
a little bit so there's a lot I want to
do here with you
let's talk orphan X first I'm a little
bit just about your work what got you
into rulers you know the only thing I
ever wanted to do is write thrillers and
my parents did not let me watch TV when
I was growing up unless there was Alfred
Hitchcock movie on or the Red Sox were
all my dad's from Boston so that was
religion and so all that I did was read
and so I was like climbing the
bookshelves to get to you know jaws on
the top shelf and Stephen King I mean I
was just into all that stuff by by fifth
grade and I was obsessed with it and I
still remember reading Salem's Lot like
under my bed with a flashlight I was 25
years old yeah but my parents were out
and I remember just being terrified and
just thinking it's it's insane to me
that this guy Stephen King can take a
combination of familiar words and put
them together in an unfamiliar way and
elicit this much emotion in me yeah this
is the only thing I wanted to do so I
started to write these mysteries with
like crayon illustrations at that age
and I went to college studied English
and psychology that's where I met Jordan
because I thought that'd be the best
combination of majors and I started my
first novel when I was when I went to
Harvard yeah
hey College you could say this place in
Cambridge yeah and so basically I
started my first book when I was 19 and
then I got supremely lucky and sold it
you know and kind of never had to have a
real job yeah does that is that how it
feels to you still like a job like when
I was just looking through your
Wikipedia today and all the cool things
that you've done and all the comic books
that I've grown up you know reading
the characters that everybody cares
about it doesn't it doesn't feel real it
so I can't believe I get paid to do it
like I love it so much I sort of wake up
and float down the hall to my office on
a you know barge of gratitude I just
it's so great and the comics were blast
I mean the comics are like when you get
into Marvel in DC it's like that super
rich kid who used to live up the street
from you had all the best toys and you
could go to their house and play with
their toys
yeah that's Marvel and DC yes like do
you wanna I still remember my first call
for more of all the editor-in-chief was
a very good friend axel Alonso was a fan
of some of my books and called and said
you can have sort of any character from
the Marvel vaults oh man and I had to be
super calm and cool and collected but my
inner geek boys do the cartwheels I know
you love this stuff and it's like it's
in our cells and so I said you know I
want to do the Punisher because the
Punisher was the end-all be-all there's
a lot of Punisher in orphan ax2 I mean
you can a lot of Batman you can see this
and basically I wound up writing that
they wanted someone from outside of
comics because Garth Ennis had completed
his legendary run and they wanted to
kind of reboot it and I still remember I
have this totally surreal experience
where I went to the bookstore right here
in Ventura I'm sorry the comic book shop
and I could no longer buy my favorite
comic because I was writing it like I
already knew what what happened and it
was completely wow that's real comic
book in there somewhere I was wild yeah
so are you more of a Marvel guy or a DC
guy I'm to ask I don't know that you
legally can answer that
you're more Marvel yeah I'm more of a
mark yeah I am more Marvel with the
exception of Batman I mean I love Hulk
Spider I was a hardcore spider-man like
you know and I had every Punisher
appearance what I make of sort of the
way the movies have gone down because
it's so clear that Marvel has just
figured out how to do these movies
correctly and at least from my opinion
DC all the Wonder Woman the standalone
it was good like they just can't quite
practice right although the original
Batman yeah the Christian Bale that
means well yeah well those Batman's so I
wrote Batman The Dark Knight that you
have here so I my Batman series it was
very much it has an homage to those
films it wasn't the mean Batman title
just Batman who's Batman The Dark Knight
and I was very focused on reinventing
the villains I love villains and I love
dealing with darkness and giving them a
very legitimate viewpoint which is
probably part of the perspective
shifting that I think that I'm capable
of doing in politics I can see a lot of
other sides and a lot of valid reasons
for it well I can also see this is why
you can you know do some things with
Jordan because he always talks about you
have to give the devil his due and I
guess you really have to do that if
you're gonna write a good villain right
oh yeah I mean the bad guy never thinks
he's the bad guy right so it's like the
more I think younger writers and me
included you know my early stuff it's
like the worst possible serial killer
villain you think that makes your guy a
better force for good and what you
realize is if you can actually build a
steel man instead of a straw man like
someone who has a reason rationale and
worldview that we almost start to relate
to as a villain like it's right there
mm-hmm and then your guide defeats him
even through that chaos and ambiguity
that actually accrues way more
positively to your protagonist than if
he's just you know tracking serial
killers all day yeah serial killers
inherently aren't that interesting from
a narrative perspective because it's
like why did he do it oh he's insane you
know if you can find people with a real
rationale which is what I do for it's
what I really do in the orphan axis but
I did that with penguin with scarecrow
with you know the Mad Hatter I tried to
give them an inner life that shows the
reflection mm-hmm of Batman it's sort of
like that Buffalo Bill wasn't really the
interesting bad guy in Silence of the
Lambs
it was Hannibal Lecter right like the
psychopath yeah there were the
straight-up murdering psychopath oh yeah
it was more about the the intricacies of
the psychological piece well in that
structured like a love story right
that's a love story between Hannibal
Lecter and Clarice Starling mm-hmm
right didn't end that well for well well
for them it did for them it did I didn't
end that well for the guy I mean yeah
there's a dance and there's a flirtation
and so it's very much about them you
know it's this very weird twisted foray
into intimacy between two opposite
parties and so it's structured out like
a romance
we should recut that as a rom-com
I'm sure somebody's done that dude
somewhere so for somebody that's
interested in stories and these
archetypal characters and as you know
I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson right
now how much truth do you think people
can get out of these stories because
Jordan's always talking about you know
the truth that you can extrapolate from
religious stories but then also does
relate it that you can get truth from
well-written fiction like you know he
talks about Harry Potter a lot or the
story of Pinocchio or just different
things when you're writing these things
are you really keeping that in mind yeah
you know that's a really interesting
question I mean I I believe I'm a
hardcore young yet I mean I first
studied young under Jordan my my thesis
if anybody like if ambien doesn't work
my thesis was 14 and Jungian analysis
from Shakespearean tragedy I mean I
posit that Shakespeare was his tragedies
are like perfect thrillers right they're
highly structured convention boundary
interpretations of past themes that are
narrative ly driven of lust intrigue and
murder designed to appeal the broadest
possible cross-section of people but I'm
a hardcore Jungian in that I do believe
that the hero myth is as essential and
evolutionarily selected as opposable
thumbs and eyelids like you can find a
tribe cut off from all human contact
buried deep in the Amazon and you know
they're gonna have opposable thumbs you
know they're gonna have eyelids and you
know that they're gonna have a hero myth
with all the constituent parts so then
the question is well why and so what I
believe is that I mean what I believe
what what Jung believes what Jordan
talks about a lot is that there's
essential wisdom that's embedded then in
my mind is more is a more real truth
than the kind of truths that we deal
with on the surface in a lot of ways of
how to contend with the unknown both
internally and externally so you buy in
if we were looking at this sort of Sam
Harris Jordan debate on this you buy
Jordans version of that that it's beyond
just fact that can give us truth it's
that there has to be some other sort of
story on top of that yes I think we're
story processing and story making
machines yeah that you can't get value
out of just fact alone basically yeah I
mean you need to you need to embed
something
in some archetypal structure so I always
think of it like we're preconditioned to
have and you know it's complicated
because people think when you talk about
the Jungian collective unconscious
people think that like somewhere
floating in our prefrontal cortex is the
notion of a wizened old woman as
representing wisdom but I don't think
it's that I think that there's a story
engine that is selected that drives
people to say okay I need a
representation for wisdom so if you look
around your village or your city or your
community that will tend to land on
somebody who's older like it's ingrained
in them so you there's different choices
that happen I don't believe that that
there's sort of essential specifics that
are floating in our head but the
mechanism to make to make meaning is in
there and the mechanism to look at
different things that are in the world
around us and to plug in symbols and to
make them construct a certain way and
that's why if you look at like the Epic
of Gilgamesh it's a direct overlay for
The Terminator
right I mean so there's all these
overlaps and nuance between the ways
that we're used to processing story yeah
what do you make of the fact that it
seems like the only thing we can
seemingly do right in Hollywood these
days is make superhero movies is there
some like extra meaning to that right
now like we're making blockbuster after
blockbuster or at least Marvel is just
blowing it out of the water with all
these things and we don't seem to be
making a lot of new original stories
anymore well I'm a little I'm divided on
that I mean my favorite movie last year
was Wind River I don't know if you saw I
didn't say that I think I heard of it
Taylor Sheridan is the writer director
he also wrote hell or high water and he
wrote Sicario okay he's amazing
so there's interesting work that's being
done I mean I think there's a
preponderance of superhero stuff because
as we are sort of laying waste to some
of the structures that have protected us
in a lot of ways it's sort of the new
gods in the new mythology I mean in the
case of Thor literally right and so I
think that it's there it's this overlay
for us to contend with and make meaning
with with bigger symbols in our life I
mean it's so weird I love Batman right
you're a Batman guy too yes by being a
Marvel guy yeah but it was so funny cuz
out the other day and there was a guy
with like a Batman wallet and a Batman
tattoo and a Batman shirt and I was like
we're
grown man what are we doing what does
mean right mean you have a wallet it's
sort of like is it that different than
having a cross around your neck like why
are we if you like it if you like a
comic if you like a movie why are we
necessarily like in graining that in our
skin right and having that be in our on
our clothes like why would we wear this
with a shield and I think there's a lot
of a sort of religious overlay to what
these represent yeah well the stories
write these stories of good and evil in
the way Star Wars at least the originals
affected me or the way now I mean you
can get so much truth and interesting
deep profound psychological thought out
of the the original Batman trilogy it's
incredible yeah well good and evil and
laying waste to the world I mean that
Heath Ledger Joker is just a
manufacturing yeah well so it's funny so
you look at there's sort of we have a
direct line with Star Wars in some ways
because you have a young who has a
fairly impenetrable cannon like he's not
breathing reading you know you can read
Freud and the case studies read like
short stories I mean so it's obvious for
me in hindsight why studied it but
things never make sense when you're just
following things that you love and I was
super interested in psychoanalysis and
in hindsight it's like of course all
young wrote about was narrative mmm-hmm
and all Freud wrote about was you know
interesting psychological case studies
which are also narrative based and they
read like short stories but so you have
a young who's very tough to penetrate so
you have Joseph Campbell who came along
I think of Campbell is like the
cliffnotes for young I don't think
Campbell has a lot of stuff that if you
you know like Jung's tricky you know
he's like reading young it takes a lot
of work and focus so Campbell makes that
more accessible and then Campbell had
you know that's where Bill Moyer that
famous interview right and Lucas then
specifies that makes it specific in a
way and when you're talking about
meaning in stories that sort of thing
it's like no one will deny you can find
meaning from Freud and Jung right but
when that's distilled down to something
that's specific that embodies those
principles that's the thing that sort of
tattooed on our spinal cords in this
culture like who didn't have that
experience with Star Wars yeah right who
doesn't show up with that and that's
because it's taking these things that
are litter
philosophical psychological meaning
making human beings in these bodies in
these cannons and distilling it down to
something that everybody can plug into
whether you get it at whatever level you
get it out you get it out seeing those
that seven is different than us seeing
them at 30 or 40 yeah so when Jordan
takes that to the religious place do you
follow that thinking there
yeah and I'm from like an atheist Jewish
you know semi socialist background you
know like I'm not conventionally
religiously raised you know it's like to
deny that a story isn't that successful
so here's a weird thing that's always an
issue that I have with with Democrats I
know you get very defensive when people
have problems with Democrats oh yes
there's this funny thing where Democrats
tend to view other cultures with like
great reverence especially the more
exotic they are even if there's some
fundamental issues in the other cultures
that should be relevant right like you
have hardcore feminists who are
supporting certain regimes that treat
women terribly and you're like we should
jar out of that like that appreciation
for the exotic and the one thing I find
frustrating is we have such a collection
of different cultures in the United
States and it's like why can't you go to
Alabama or the deep south I love the
deep south like when I saw my first book
I drove through the deep south to go to
the bourbon distilleries and to see
Faulkner's home and why don't you look
at that and people's relationship with
the Second Amendment and their
relationship with each other and their
relationship with their value system as
also being a culture that is different
that should be appreciated right we
don't it's it's a weird thing and so so
we do it for the outward world but sort
of not just right enough to be safely
exotic yeah right but if someone
disagrees with you and looked this is
true both ways I mean I'm not I'm not
merely beating up Democrats but it's a
frustration that I've had to say people
think differently so if you want to
pretend that you're gonna jump into
their brain and make a moral judgment on
why they hold their opinions that's not
good for anybody
but the same thing holds true for
stories it's like going to any
university and it's super cool and hip
to talk about to analyze the Marvel
stories or to analyze Star Wars and it's
like why wouldn't you do the same with a
story that is so successful that it
Dwarfs all of those over centuries and
centuries that his you know given rise
- you know cathedrals and and and and
Wars and like this is stuff that is
moved right right right so it's like if
you're into those stories it's like yeah
that was that was yesterday you know
that's we are like you know Jesus Freak
yeah wait a minute like write a story
somebody that guys at the Star Wars
convention yeah exactly yeah and it's
like most of what's the story of Jesus
like if you if you shoulder your own
burden if you bear your own cross and
accept your own suffering that's only
means toward to transforming it or to
transcending it I should say and so it's
like oh is that relevant in
relationships or psychology like what's
the best approach if someone's really
screwed up and complaining and as a
murder in the whole world like you go
yeah honey the world's awful like is
that the parenting that you want or to
say what it what are the things you're
doing where are the faults as they exist
in you one thing the Jews are great on
the Old Testament the gods angry we
screwed up right Jordan Jordan says that
alive yeah it's like where is it
centered in you and what is the way that
you can accept the conditions and the
inherent tragedy of life in a way that
allows you to transcend this and it's
like that's played again and again and
again I mean you look at Tony Scott
Denzel Washington's man on fire mm-hmm
and it's like you look at how
beautifully that takes an hour in the
first act just the relationship between
him and the girl and it's basically a
classic like you need to become a
monster to hunt monsters but it's the
story of his salvation and sacrifice for
something innocent it's just it's that's
my favorite modern memory problem what
do you make of the fact that people
actually care about this stuff right now
like this type of conversation and being
able to relate it to either comic books
or movies and still talk about religion
or talk about it from an atheist
perspective that people actually care
about this we're I think four years ago
if a whole bunch of us had been talking
about this people would be like what the
hell like I like this relevant what what
you guys live in your mom's base right
well that's what they'd be saying
covered would snack crumbs yeah that may
well be true but I cleaned up before I
came up so I mean I think what's
interesting is there's a letter F scott
Fitzgerald sent to his editor and it's
great because he talks about all the
notes that you get from an editor and he
said the American reading public is
totally stupid it needs to be led by the
nose or number two massively brill
and can interpret every problem that you
have more like it's it's everything it's
just a morphus view that we always take
towards society mm-hmm and so there's
this view of like the American attention
span is shortening you look at it like
we went from books to blogs to kind of
MySpace you had to build out to Facebook
to Twitter to Instagram like this ever
shrinking aspect but it's too simplistic
I mean everything's too simplistic so we
have podcasts exploding audio books and
publishing exploding and this sort of
longer form discourse I mean what I
think is really interesting is there's a
lot of people were hungry for it they
always say to Jordan it makes no sense
at all that he did a lecture series on
the psychological underpinnings of the
Bible and more than three people showed
up like it just you wouldn't anticipate
that but people are a lot smarter and
are a lot more oriented in their desire
for meaning then we give credit I can
tell you that from being on this tour
with him in the middle he'll often say
something about how he's working on the
next series of biblical lectures right
it gets a huge applause every time like
people want more of that absolutely
whether they're believers or not I think
many of the people that watch them and
appreciate them actually aren't
believers at least in a in a traditional
sense well I mean and who knows what
that means like i am.i a believer or
like do I believe those stories contain
some of the the most fundamental grains
of first principles of orienting oneself
in the world absolutely so it's like
what does it even mean to be a believer
yeah but I mean the other thing if I'm
really interesting with it is that it's
sort of going back to our conversation
about archetypes and my belief that it's
selected is we were sort of
meaning-making creatures and so if if
there's a discussion that Jordan has if
you guys are in conversation on a stage
or Eric's arguing with Ben right you get
these opposing views within this group
mm-hmm people are engaged in that if
they're if it feels like there's a
genuine focus for for meaning because
it's like that's the thing that we want
more than anything and it gets hijacked
a lot for the purpose to be like I just
want to be happy and it's like happiness
is temporary now this is ephemeral so if
I think that's what's happening with
these longer form discussions that
people are engaged in is because it
feels like there's something real
happening and it's not buzzwords and
cliches
facile dismissals it's it's something
that's real it's almost like also at the
same time mainstream has become so
meaningless right that our ability to
just do this and have a little bit of an
exchange maybe with some differences and
some agreements has that much more value
right now where 10 years ago maybe it
wouldn't have had so much value but the
but as mainstream careens off into the
abyss well we're still here
well it's funny too because in some ways
a reasonable centrist view is now
radical right so if you have a senator
who's willing to compromise and interact
with the other side to pass legislation
which is one of the tenants of how
Congress said was the first order how it
over right that's sort of radical like
you don't only vilify and shut down from
either side and and continue to polarize
and actually I you know part of this
I've been thinking a lot about how this
is driven with mainstream media and you
and I were talking a little bit about
trying to use the intellectual dark web
as an ability to to sort of broaden out
what views are of different parties and
you know it's all heterodoxy base but
like how do we bring in centrist views
and have them represented because one of
the things I've been thinking about a
lot I've been doing a lot of candidate
training I've talked to dozens of
candidates from you know Tennessee to
Alabama like all over the country
virtually no one that I talked to is
making it a keep key aspect of their
platform
you know trans bathrooms and democratic
socialism so there's like wait is there
a role that we're all playing you know
even in this umbrella of the
intellectual dark web but then the
mainstream media everyone who is sort of
virtue signaling on social media in
starting to think you know Eric calls it
the Chihuahua effect like there's very
loud people who are out at the edges and
like maybe good for them right like I'm
not in favor of deep platforming anybody
yeah on either on either edge but
there's a huge story in the middle that
I think isn't being told and I think
it's really important to to have the
Chihuahua effect not kau everyone in the
middle from being able to sort of speak
up and have the discourse that they want
to have yeah you know one of the things
I told our with the
Washington Post have sat down with some
other places and said look count the
number of times that you've written
about for instance Acacio right like so
she won in a very deep low district like
good on her go off in the Bronx and win
and see what your what's gonna work
there mm-hmm that's not my proclivity
but I'm not denigrating that but it's
like how many times have you written
about her verse versus Angie Craig Haley
Stephens Joseph cops are Ken horrible
all these amazing former military
pro-business
amazing Democratic candidates yeah and
I'm guessing that ninety percent of the
people watching haven't heard one of
those names yeah and she was all over
everything endlessly for weeks and and
everyone does that so I've been trying
to think about why why that is the case
you know I would bet if you go to the
New York Times or The Washington Post
she's mentioned you know 10x 20x these
other candidates if not even more mm-hmm
so I think from the right it makes sense
and the left does this too so this is
not me claiming that the right someone
who does this it makes sense to paint
the party is further left than it is
because it's it's an easier sort of
target to paint the furthest extreme and
then to denigrate that but with the left
they're doing it also I think because
there's problems and they need clickbait
Nye balls so I think there's that yeah
and I think there's also a sort of
curious there's a curious desire on the
part of the left sometimes to continue
to be martyred right and I don't know if
if sometimes there's a drive to apt to
further the stories that are stories
that in fact are gonna hurt the left an
example of that is when we talk about
progress that's being made there's a lot
of progress being made in race relations
for for women in business there's a
propensity for the left to say
everything's as bad as it ever was
nothing's gotten better and you go
really like you like today it's the same
like this is not to say that there isn't
problematic widespread racism you know
but easier really the same as in turns
before the civil rights is really the
same as in Jim Crow that nothing's
changed and it comes I think from a
concern that if you concede that things
are better than everyone will just give
up and go home there's like a driver to
it and so I think that there's this
aspect with how the Left engages with
progress on what candidates that it
looks at that it's almost and I think
the right does has its own version of
this there
almost a desire to be constantly upset
and outraged or to constantly be under
the heel of what's viewed as the other
side and what I'm noticing a lot in the
discourse that is the most advocated or
or is the most widely spread is there's
there's a real sort of martyr mentality
that lies beneath the outrage from
either side
mm-hmm okay so let's just back up a
little bit so we come from a pretty
similar political background ending both
pretty much Democrats our whole life
both part of the left the whole thing I
think we differ a little bit now and
that I basically think that the ship has
sailed on this thing yeah I do think
that the the left has just rotted the
Democrats from the inside I get that
there are these good people and I look
forward to have and many of them sit in
that very chair and I'll hope that some
things can return but I think it's gonna
get a lot worse before it gets better
you're really trying to help the
messaging of this thing yeah to focus
the messaging but basically it get rid
of some of the identity politics stuff
maybe stop doing so much class warfare
stuff I think a few other a few other
pieces of this convinced me that it's
possible well you're right first of all
that I bet if we sat down and did a
chart of our political views my I think
yours and mine are the closest of
anybody in the intellectual darkweb
probably like you and I are probably
aligned on everything from you know gun
discipline to abortion like if you go
down the list yeah and you're right that
the biggest difference is like you've
left the party and you and I'm trying to
wring I have enjoyed a new party but
just for the record but I don't consider
myself a democratic iew politically if
that's a party out join that party yeah
and I'm trying to kind of refocus the
party in a way that it lives up to the
promise I think it has specifically to
win people like you back yeah it's a
long road there's a lot of hurdles and
there's a lot of Quagmire's and we have
been there are a lot of errors that have
been made and I think that one of them
is I I believe that corruption is a very
widespread problem I don't think that
that the Democrats can
continue to make an argument that were
the less corrupt of two parties I don't
think that's a winning organ yeah I
think you could probably make the
counter-argument pretty easily all right
I mean the Democrats did a lot of stuff
against Bernie and and Donna Brazile and
the questions to Hillary and all sorts
of other stuff you could argue they're
probably more corrupt you know yeah
that's that might be another I don't
even think that's an important argument
to have anymore because I think put it
this way let's assume from my
perspective let's just take the leap to
say I believe the Democrats are less
corrupt than then then what is happening
right now under under this
administration and the stuff that's
going on okay I don't think we can have
an argument that says vote for us we're
corrupt but just kind of like I don't
think that's a winning argument right
and I think if we're gonna engage with
people like you
you know libertarians you know
Republicans the first thing they're
gonna say when it comes to corruption
validly so is like oh you want to clean
up corruption okay you first
mmm that's a reasonable first claim for
people who have been in the party and
feel that they're lost and so a lot of
the hope that I have with the party
are these new candidates and voices and
as part of my dismay about the way that
it's painted that the far left is what's
getting the most attention or or like
the ridiculous
Bobby stuff that happens on college
campuses like a lot of the attention
that it's sort of like claiming that
every person who's on the right is is
you know a radicalized neo-nazi it's
like so where is where is the internal
pushback on that cuz I can see it this
way that from someone that was always a
lefty and a Democrat and I progressive
the whole thing and now although I still
consider myself liberal I definitely if
someone had me for four hours here I
could probably get to the point where
I'd say I'm a libertarian I see I see
intellectual flexibility on the right
these days I see a libertarian side I
see the never Trump ER as I see the
Trump errs I see sort of the mugged
lefties like I do see like a couple
different pillars that are all sort of
white lefties the mug the mug lefties
what I would say like I feel like a mug
left mugged now you know but then I see
like a couple different groups that are
thought of on the right right now that
differ on certain things but be
basically you're agreeing to disagree I
don't see that on the left but you just
mentioned a couple names that you
believe our people wellhere's yes that's
what I think is happening and it goes to
your point about where the oxygen is but
if if it's if there's some evidence of
it I'd love to see it I mean there and
here is a trail of candidates I mean I
could list 20 candidates which I won't
just rattle off yeah you said people
don't necessarily know you know Katie
Hill and Haley Stephens and and Kendra
Horne yeah I'm dealing with people
everyday who were talking about number
one thing is anti-corruption and their
signing I asked yes sir I was an event
with six candidates and Adam chef mm-hmm
and I said you know I'd worked with some
of them I'm working with others I said
have all of you signed on on the
disclose Act disclose act is vowing to
name lobbyists all lobbyist influence
it's all to get money out of politics
which I which I think is the number one
issue isn't business it's it's sort of
the donor class level and influence of
lobbyists like I think that's a really
big problem and do you disclose
everybody you just close your donors
which I'm going to talk more about from
a libertarian perspective in a second
because I had a very interesting
conversation with ban that shifted some
of my thinking on that lobbyists right
you're gonna name all your lobbyists are
you gonna come out for protection of the
vote no matter what right are you gonna
come out hard against taking PAC money
for individual candidates or like
bombing the other side through a PAC
anti gerrymandering right which means
either a bipartisan committee that does
it which has some problems or judicial
or I'm increasingly starting to think
about that there's a congregational
effects like if you really great to have
Congress doing a lot more Mac and if
they did anything right so it's swearing
a bunch of things before they're going
forward there's a dozens and dozens of
names on the list of people who've
signed on to this cause act and I
believe they're all Democrats they're
all younger Democrats with this wave now
the disclosed thing is troubling for me
because you get stupid stuff like this
in and out boycott the lot of the day in
a yeah yeah which if people aren't
familiar with it I think somebody called
they found out the in and out had
donated to Republicans and called for a
boycott and the best thing in Southern
California everyone's like dude that's
in and out
yeah but then they found out that they'd
given money to Democrats like the whole
thing is this mess and so and I
understand and things are also
complicated like Nike right now has
Colin Kaepernick's the face of that
they're calling them the six billion
dollar man they rent the ground floor of
Trump Tower for thirteen million dollars
a year okay they've given three times as
much money to Republicans as Democrats
so it's like who are we boycotting and
meanwhile there is a sandwich chain that
just got put out of business because the
owner took a picture with Trump right so
it's like from both sides it's like what
are we doing everyone's burning their
Nikes but they're actually paying thirty
million dollars to rent space and are
giving three-act right there using
sweatshops in you know China or Vietnam
or wherever and now suddenly everyone on
the Left it's cool with that because
they want to support Nike because right
now I'm in the ends but also everybody
in the right is sort of outraged by this
move and they're they're burning their
shoes but like he also is given
three-act it's like let's not look for
our moral guidance maybe from
corporations like maybe that's a good so
that that's it I would say not your
moral guidance nor from politicians I
don't think I'd be getting it from
politicians or I mean people look at
politicians now as if they're supposed
to be superheroes yeah and they're just
people who are yeah middle management
pushing things one way or another a
little bit but instead we want people to
come in with magical powers and fix
things that haven't been able to be
fixed for all of humanity yeah I mean I
think there there are certain standards
to which we want politicians held like
we want doctors and lawyers like there's
certain oaths of the office if someone's
life is being run by lobbyists it's like
that's a problem but to go back just
real quickly to that to that concern
which is if you just close everything
then people can kind of mob you and
boycott you we've seen that from both
sides in a way that just becomes a mess
and then companies like might one of my
biggest protests actually isn't moral
it's that it makes everything boring
right it just makes it so dull that
anytime somebody takes over your
comedian guess what you live on the edge
if you live on the edge you're gonna say
stuff sometimes that doesn't play or
stuff that's offensive look at Richard
Pryor look at any Murphy look at Dave
Chappelle you know you're a comedian
yeah I mean the whole game is to do that
and maybe you're gonna miss and fall
down yeah and and I think got a cell
phone in the
crowd waiting just waiting to click send
right and then that one work Raven
nonsense apologies to who well who is
who is like curled in a fetal position
in their shower because they've Ruby
need a joke that was mean about
something yeah like I just don't who are
you who do people apologize to but so
one of the things and I know that this
is an issue I mean this is one of the
other things I know that this closing is
a problem from a libertarian perspective
because why shouldn't people just give
money and let's say that somebody's in
LA and they're Christian and they give
money to a pro-family anti-gay marriage
group it's like maybe they don't want to
be outed if it means they're never gonna
work again
and so I understand those concerns and
so one of the things that I'm sort of
discussing and advocating is to raise
the floor of that to some number and I
don't know what it is but these are
conversations that are being had
internally and obviously the Democratic
Party is the one pushing all this this
is not my invention but this is
something that I find to be important
with the candidates who were running to
talk about but maybe there's some floor
where we say look five thousand or ten
thousand dollars give what you want in
its secret but if you're giving over ten
thousand dollars you want to be a
political player and then maybe have the
spine to stand behind your money then
and I know that that's not like I will
concede that that is running against the
current of what a libertarian argument
would be yeah but when I'm weighing that
against you know millions of dark money
that no one knows where it's from if
it's in the country out of the country
going up to take out candidates like
that's us that's a sacrifice that I'm
interested in making yeah well that's
one of those middle ground things that I
think is worth having the conversation
about because I don't I'm not someone
that would say there should be no
government involvement in any an issue
so you have to figure out all right
you're gonna be a real player in this
then maybe that does have nice was that
that actually does make sense to me
unfortunately this isn't where you get a
lot of headlines have oh people are
trying to figure out what what the fair
balance is on what to disclose but
wouldn't it be cool you know it's like
we have this thing and it's one of
things I talked so much about messaging
you walk into a big rally you say I
believe universal health care is our
right everyone's immediately in their
camp looks like yeah and there's
cheering and it's wonderful or like
there's no way I worked so hard my whole
life I paid for my own health care why
can't people do it and what you just
said about there's a reason
ground in the middle and these are
conversations I think that are essential
is like everything's in the middle it's
like okay well you know we think
everyone should have some standard of
health care so people aren't dying in
the streets in America right that's fun
American and it's unethical it's also a
massive public health issue if people
just die in their bodies are rotting or
missing they're also paying for it
either way well exactly you know so like
so it's an economic argument like let's
not pretend let's not fight over an
abstract notion of whether universal
health care is a right or a privilege
like that doesn't actually do anything
for people who need health care
so instead do we look at it and go okay
average cost of an emergency room visit
is one thousand two hundred thirty three
dollars hospital passes on there an
insurance company who passes it on to us
because they're uninsured and our rates
go up or vaccination is $19 so let's
have some dollars and cents discussions
and let's also talk to people from
around the table even who we might
disagree with about how we get into that
and it was interesting because I was on
with Jordan and we jumped on the phone
with Ben when I was talking through some
of this stuff about like like I was
trying to figure out there's any good
argument for gerrymandering aside from
the fact that everyone from either party
just gets to keep their jobs so why
would you point of interest to me is
like to call someone like you and be
like make an argument for gerrymandering
right I can know what it is and so I was
kind of having this conversation and and
you know getting pushback from Ben about
this disclosure thing for exactly the in
and out reasons and it's like okay well
he and I aren't gonna agree you know
it's like he's he's gonna his his
opinion is get all money out of
government and then no one's gonna
compete for it right it's a very
different solution of the one that I
advocate but in hearing that I think
there's a way to address concerns that
reasonable people will have to say I
want to give to $2,500 through candidate
I don't want the whole neighborhood to
know like what if it's more liberal and
I'm in Alabama right what if it's more
conservative and I'm in San Francisco
and so it's ways to sort of hear where
people are coming from and try to figure
out ways to discuss that and so the
biggest hope when you said to convince
me for me is this next generation of
leadership in the Democratic Party
there's amazing you know there's a guy
Joseph cops are in Texas who twenty
years he was an Army Ranger professor at
West Point went to the
Hannity school got a degree started his
own business you know created hundreds
of jobs for people and taxes and is now
running for a seat interesting guy very
common sense geared goes into churches
goes into Republican strongholds and
sits down and will have a conversation
with anybody who can see their in half
hold his own with you so this does show
why the media or the way they frame all
this is so much of the problem because
no one has heard of any of these people
and if you control the information that
we're getting were shifting the views on
the party and I feel the same way in
inverse about Trump voters like you're
you're hearing from them and people are
saying it's it's guys with torches at
midnight protecting Confederate statues
and it's like wait a minute I have an
incredibly wide array of friends I have
a very broad cross-section of friends
who voted for Trump and it's too
widespread for me to dismiss everybody
is being mouth-breathing troglodytes
there's no way I have very smart friends
I friends who were in the military
they're a bunch of people made different
decisions there's people who think that
we need anything as long as it wasn't
another bush or another Clinton I don't
care what it is they wanted a disruption
and I think that it's really important
to look at the way that the media is
telling that and part of what I think
our job is or people like us know is to
sort of cut through that and to try and
have a conversation about what's really
going on and for me with the Democrats
it's like I can as I said I mean to have
people sit down or look at it angie
craig or kendra horn or you know ken
Harbaugh someone I just spoke with last
week you know another guy was in the
military did an emergency relief
organization afterwards help 80,000
people like you talk to him he's talking
about health care and jobs and education
yeah would you say that most of these
folks are against identity politics and
just sort of the general state of when
people talk about the left what it's
become would you say that they're in
opposition to what I think are most of
the concerning parts left the concerning
parts yes I mean what's hard is I at
least the parts that we seem to be
concerned yes here's what's hard with
identity politics is it's one of these
terms that means very different things
to different people right so some people
are like identity and
you know like I'm african-american and
have an issue with actual statistics on
imprisonment rates or police brutality
and ways that that skews is one thing
saying you can't have cultural
appropriation and I'm melting down over
white male privilege because you know
Justin Timberlake has a braid in his
hair is another thing yeah and all of
those are sort of different and chopped
up and it's like I like for me nobody
like I haven't had one conversation
about trans bathrooms or white male
privilege or any of these things with
the candidates it doesn't mean that they
are not more inclined based on their
political orientation and their big five
personality traits right Iran that the
IR openness to have sympathy for those
arguments or the arguments that are
beneath those arguments where people are
coming from but the very far left stuff
about it like a day without white people
and you know what evergreen evergreen
brass no I'm not hearing that stuff
anywhere yeah so it gets a little tricky
because for me I feel like we can't have
it be that all immigration is bad or all
immigration is good like you're talking
about meeting in the middle with stuff
it's library one in this country is the
descendant of an immigrant basically
yeah unless you heard maybe all Native
American or brought here right and we
also can't make an argument that all
immigration is good so maybe if we can
put down those bats that were simply
beating each other with and actually sit
down and talk to what the concerns are
it could be a conversation you said
something very interesting about when
you were on with ban or ban was on with
you I don't remember we're talking about
abortion and your your you support
choice yeah I consider myself but
grudgingly pro-choice yeah and I want
we've cut off basically yeah and but
it's like you you conceded which I
thought was really interesting because
I'm always trying to look at this issue
and you approach an issue that's
incredibly emotional with like it
actually is an issue with very good
people on both sides well that's the
abortion ones the most interesting to me
because it's so obvious that both sides
have a principled position to the start
one doesn't want to control the woman's
body one doesn't want one wants to make
sure that this child is taken care of
and has the right to life and all that
so it's like if we can at least
acknowledge that now we can start
discussion on some of the science we can
start discussing some of this
responsibilities of government and
everything else but we're getting to
trouble is when we impugn the motives of
another side because nobody knows we
don't even know our own motives half the
time so for me to say you just said that
let me tell you what your moral failings
are let me tell you where you're not in
command of your own you know moral
nature to be flawed to make this
argument right any time we get that from
the other sides the reaction is
obviously like a heisman to that but
what you said that I thought was the
most courageous thing that you said and
I think it's the I think it is the it's
the the tectonic plate under which so we
can sort of build solutions as you said
look I concede that part of my argument
is arbitrary like how about what you say
twenty twenty weeks so right so I
obviously weeks in a day how about if
she's raped and she's gonna die but it's
21 weeks there it we have to concede
that we are not absolute in our views
and some things are absolute for people
right but it's like when we're talking
about immigration right when we're
talking about gun discipline it's like
there's certain stuff where if you go in
same thing where everyone raise your
hand who's for gun control everyone's
gonna immediately go into their two
camps but you can go in and say look
guys what politicians in the media
always want to make it seem like this is
an all-or-nothing proposition that
anything that's a slippery slope we're
gonna just slide all the way to the
bottom right if we make any impingement
on on second Amendment rights that
everyone's gonna take our guns away and
the other side is like hey anything that
you come for me for this
if I give any ground it's going to get
worse and everybody's really entrenched
in that and it's like we're already on a
slippery slope so what do you think we
need to break that because it seems to
me that I'm with you we've got these two
sides kind of going in polar opposite
directions you know I've spent more time
talking about one side that I used to be
part of because that's where I was but I
get it we got two sides doing this
casually scoring lover thing too hard
you do that well that's why I said
mugged left the other floor I think
Brett Weinstein said that I have PTSD
basically but what whatever it is you
you you when you're part of something
you can recognize it there and look if
ten years from now if I'm hanging out
with all these libertarians and that
they're all crazy I'll call them out you
know what I mean like I just think it's
it's just human nature you can go to
what you know and where you were it's
almost like we need something crazy to
happen I don't even know what I mean by
this exactly to break this thing we can
talk about it rationally right and the
whole IDW crew can talk about how to
have these conversations and agree to
disagree and I you know been in the the
gay cake and all that like I can try to
hopefully he'll bake me a cake one day
now that I think is a particularly good
Baker but like we can do that for the
next 50 years that discussion but it
almost seems to me we're on this like
slide to something really horrible is
gonna happen again I don't know exactly
what I mean but it's like what would it
take to wake people up to this we're all
talking about it and no one's actually
stopping it from happening well I never
table dissent I think in a weird way
when everyone's looking at the sort of
Trump phenomenon right which came out of
nowhere
seemingly but really didn't yeah I think
that part of the vote for him and for
you know a 70 something year old
Democratic Socialist from Vermont I
think was that I think was a reaction to
that then people said the status quo
isn't gonna work anymore like I said I
don't care who it is it's not gonna be
another brush it's not gonna be there
Clinton and you know I might I might
disagree with the choices that some
people made but I can't disagree with
the driving anger and frustration that
underlay that and you know Eric talks
about the sort of three big lies that
have been put forth you know one is that
all immigration is good right the other
is that with trade a rising tide lifts
all ships the third is that there's zero
connection whatsoever between terrorism
and Islam they're totally unhooked I add
a fourth though Eric thinks it's less
relevant but I think that it's the
argument that that biology has no basis
whatsoever and in gender definition or
in in you know sexuality that there's
that there's that that seems like a huge
one of these days yeah I mean Eric
believes that that's less widespread but
I think that culturally that that
position is so weaponizing
yeah that I think that that's an
equivalent one and I think that what
you're seeing is a reaction to these
absolutes that everybody knows that a
gut-level aren't true and it's like
everybody's enter
painting them on the surface everybody's
having a conversation which is you know
I believe only in open borders or I
believe we have to shut down borders and
separate families and then it's it's
like these poles are so crazy and I
think that they're both groups are
motivated to protect their further left
or right compatriots I mean so we're
having this movement that's going out in
that direction but I think that's what
it was reaction to and I think you're
saying look where's the point of the big
bang theory that the universe of you
know explodes that it starts to come
back together yeah because I'm afraid
it's gonna have to take something
horrible and again I don't even know
what I mean like is there gonna be like
some terroristic or something that will
just remind us that these people are not
all of our enemies you know it I mean
like it's like yeah I don't want to
think of the world that you're saying
essentially what that thesis is is to
say if there's a horrible terrorist
attack the new sort of out-group threat
will get Americans back together - yeah
and there's so nobody wants that to
happen of course and there's huge danger
in what that ends up leading to because
we know how we sort of went crazy after
9/11 and Patriot Act and all that but
like it just seems to me that the wheels
on this thing although now people are
talking about it it's not slowing down
and that just leads me to believe it
gets to the ledge soon well I think the
first thing is is you know like clean up
your own kitchen first I mean that's
what I'm doing there's a guy that I'm on
tour with that's doing something about
cleaning up your own yeah yeah but see I
switched it to kitchen that was no that
was affected with yours it Jordan got
everything he knows but wait Lily let's
pause there for a second just real quick
cuz we should not gonna totally dismiss
this so you were Jordan student I was
what was that like we'll get back there
but let's just no yeah because I wanted
to do it like 20 minutes ago and if
Jordan was amazing I mean I love Jordan
from minute one you know he taught me
personality psychology I went back into
the young seminar with him and then he's
my thesis adviser he's like what mid 90s
early a graduated 95 yeah okay and he
was dynamite he's very imposing and
formal I just like right away was was
was in like I just got the saw the whole
thing and I remember telling my college
roommates I was like that's a guy who's
gonna be remembered just by his last
name like 100 years after his dad
and you know I didn't quite think it was
because he was gonna be doing you know
Kermit the Frog Hitler memes but I just
thought in an academic arena yeah he's
sort of brilliance for me was and his
pattern recognition and ability to boil
stuff down but he would even then if
somebody came in ideologically from the
left or the right and it was kind of a
hollow shell he would just puncture it
didn't have as much of he was formidable
I mean he wasn't as jokey I mean
obviously we're good friends now yeah
but he was you know he could be
intimidating to other people but I
always just really liked him and then we
stayed in touch after that he's my
thesis advisor we're very close and then
he officiated my wedding so I I'm the
only person on record to have a wedding
that like sites extensively from Canaan
even every why assume the Google Al Gore
capella going to need to know that we
had little like Gulag Archipelago like
table settings actually no but at one
point my wife and I just rewashed our
wedding video was so funny and she's
looking and you know she adores Jordan
too and Jordan was going off about
something and she she's looking up at me
and she's in her dress like we're at
that moment at the altar and she said
this is the part where I wasn't sure if
I was getting married or being trapped
like sir Jordan did a whole archetypal
analysis yeah and then you know look I
put his rules for life in orphan acts
yeah as a I have like the assassins Ten
Commandments and I wanted actually good
rules that that someone could be raised
by and then I helped him you know edit
the book and work on the book from the
neroli stage so I read it and had it in
order for next three years before his
book came out so when you when you say
that when people would come in with
arguments from either side and he could
just pop them just like that that's one
of the most interesting things to me
because if you listen again to what
mainstream is saying about him it's that
he's this is this ultra conservative or
this forced monogamy or he doesn't like
gay people or just like any of this
nonsense which every night I hear him go
up there and beat these arguments down
he beats down the arguments of identity
politics on the right I mean he's
literally every criticism of him is like
the reverse of what he's actually doing
doesn't mean he's right about everything
but it's not you know everyone is
deserving of criticism but it should be
legit criticism so it must in
when you read some of these things about
him knowing that you know this is this
isn't the guy that you learned on yeah
and you meanwhile he brings like a gay
Jew on tour with him yes it like raised
Reuters so he's a crazy Christian normal
yeah so I mean one of the jokes I have
he got accused of being an anti-semite
at some point and it was so great Eric
and I were talking about this and I
think I tweeted I'm like boy you know
Jordan did a terrible job covering up
his anti-semitism when he officiated my
wedding fifteen years ago like the most
incompetent anti-semite I've ever mashed
yeah you know it's more infuriating for
me I I feel like the media skew is so
complicated I've almost given up on us
in in certain ways look I think the
media has done an amazingly impressive
stuff like I'm I'm a big fan of the
Washington Post
despite how some things have gone so
it's like I've not I'm not giving up on
that I don't I believe that the media is
doing a really good job on cultural
issues I'm accustomed to it when people
come in and attack Jordan for being
alright it's like there is a video
online of him denouncing the hole right
for an hour if you just bother to look
into it the thing that infuriates me
more a seemingly intelligent
intellectual people who will dismiss him
or get nervous if I bring his name up
based on anything that is wildly taken
out of context and when Jordan it's like
look I was a student I've known him a
lot of years I've seen hundreds and
hundreds of hours of his lectures both
in school and here you know I helped him
with his book when he was going through
the book and he makes fun of me for that
in the acknowledgments there's nothing
that he has said that I I mean I know
his work about as well as anyone could
there's not a single thing that he said
that if you don't contextualize it
doesn't actually make sense and I have
people wholesales say oh well I have my
feelings about that it's like you know I
all mentioned doing something with him
and people who were who were seemingly
academic and I'll say did you read the
book that just is that just the plight
of doing something that is something
close to true I mean when I'm out there
with him every night and he changes the
speak you know he does an hour and a
half you know I'm warming the crowd up
he does an hour and a half then we do
like 40 minutes together at the end
but that hour to happy does he changes
it every night I see
him searching for truth every night and
it's like well actually all this hatred
and all of that non contextualized stuff
let your toilet is just that's just the
the shitty part of doing something good
right maybe like isn't that if you were
writing the character wouldn't he be
doing dealing with all this it's so
interesting so all right so two things
right like who's gonna say saying true
and then it's gonna be all good
everybody's just gonna love him that I
like it worked out so well Jesus never
got that what yeah isn't the center
right so I was thinking of that brought
up two kind of ideas for me I mean one
of them is people who are seemingly
academic and intelligent and pride
themselves on being cerebral it's like
how dare are you denigrate him cuz you
read an unflattering profile and not
read a book or listen to a lecture or do
any research beyond that but they got it
in the New York time well right I mean
or in any host of other places that have
missed the mark and then the New York
Times will come around and do something
flattering I mean it profiles a profile
and they take a point of view but like
dig deeper but what's so interesting is
you were just talking about that and
that it is such a cool thing to watch
him just like you're watching somebody
grappling with issues when he's on stage
and you've watched him do that a lot
it reminds me a bit of like the the
Abstract Expressionists I was just
thinking where Pollock started to say
the act of creation is a triumph right
so when I'm gonna paint something you're
gonna see my brushstroke right that's
laid on canvas and of course Swift and
she did a great kind of piss take on
that where he did like a carefully
painted cartoon version of that right
but were you really are seeing the work
and that the work is what is the
abstract expressionist really sort of
put the art world on their head by
elevating that the the the form and the
function for like the heroism of the
crater mm-hmm so sort of interesting is
I haven't I've noted of course that he's
grappling with things and part of him
thinking about is what's appealing like
the thing that I said that I keyed to
with you is saying look part of my
argument for pro-choice is arbitrary it
has to be we're so used to not conceding
any of that yeah so to see somebody
stand up in front of 3,000 people and go
hang on like and really be reasoning
with that in a way that you might reach
in a bag and come up with
thing is compelling and there's
something heroic about that the way that
Jackson Pollock was you know portraying
so as a writer you want to create
characters that show vulnerability
because it shows that they're human and
yet we seem to operate in a time when
almost no one is showing vulnerability
outwardly our politicians don't want to
show it our media people like everyone
wants to be perfect ever all the virtues
signaling these days everyone wants to
be like this like perfect thing so then
you get the few people that show a
little vulnerability and I guess that
has a little extra value huh that's a
good point
I mean we tend to spend less in there
just a point yeah well I see it's
interesting because we see a lot of foam
owner ability right like when it's mask
and virtue signaling like I've been
thinking about this other notion that I
have which is you know in writing
because it's sort of like why am i doing
all this stuff in politics right like
nothing makes sense till I look back on
like when I was like why would I study
you know Shakespearean tragedy Jung and
Freud and it's like oh that's that's
thrillers right that's everything that I
love but likewise with politics it's
like when you're writing well what you
want to avoid is cliche mm-hmm like it's
like your podcast like what you don't
want to do is do like whatever what
you're supposed to say everything about
you and what you do is not saying what
everyone else says and not lowering
yourself to cliche so in books you you
that's what you search for right if
there's an obvious plot turn right you
have the cop sitting outside the guy
being like this is my last day till
retirement and I'm gonna buy a yacht and
sell around the world you're like that
guy's getting killed like everything we
try and do is avoid that yeah so in
politics so much of what I'm doing is
trying to make people speak humanly and
to avoid buzzwords and so it's like I
have this theory that like as soon as
you talk about you know a woman's right
to choose that doesn't feel like it's
sufficiently complex and motivated I
understand people need to we need to
gravitate with shorthand but like I
remember growing up in the Reagan era
family of like you know we were the only
Jews in Saratoga and Silicon Valley in
my neighborhood at the time and the only
people who voted Democrat yeah
it was early days but Silicon Valley is
so diverse now but that was all the like
hewlett-packard engineers who look like
the launch guys from NASA like the
glasses in the pocket protector it was
just super it was totally geared that
not thrilled with the diversity in
Silicon Valley but that's a difference
is it not
okay yeah he's not thrilled with the
diversity of thought but you were
talking about the University of skim
coat I've thought right where was I lost
my thread I was you guys were the
outliers when you were growing up there
oh right and so everybody was talking
about family values that was a big
political thing from the right and I'm
sure you had a bit of a reaction to that
too of like well I want to talk about
family values and I just felt like what
do you mean like it's such a Republican
word that coded for all this stuff for
me now it's naturally very resistant to
it so then I grew up I get married I
have two kids and I'm like hey wait a
minute
I should have family values family
values like I it's like this new light
because the word was co-opted as a
catchphrase and when Republicans were
using it there at one time it had a rich
embodiment of meaning but when it's used
again and again and again and again in a
campaign it loses all the life to it and
the same thing happens with liberal
slogans and so it's almost like the
process of compressing information into
newsworthy sound bites and using phrases
and catchphrases the further you are
from genuine or authentic thought it's a
very similar thing of where you're
trying to reach in and do things
differently in novels or in
screenwriting or comics is a very
similar thing to the stages like don't
just shovel out a bunch of cliches like
Oh Democrats are all for redistribution
of wealth it's like no that's not what
all Democrats are for Republicans are
all you know racist and scared of
outsiders it's like no that's not what
all Republicans are and so the more that
we hear things that we've heard again
and again and again the further we're
off the mark and maybe that's why this
expansive format you know is is what's
leading to more complicated things cuz
we're not we don't have two minutes to
just sort of hold the cliches at each
other
yeah so if I'm if we're looking forward
a little bit to the elections that are
about to happen these midterms now it
seems to me that for for the decent
Democrats trying to retain some of what
old liberalism and old Democratic
messaging was there's a really tough
position here because it seems to me
that if the Democrats win it means that
the further left wing of the party wins
right now is that is that a fair
estimation I don't know I
think that's right so because you think
that these sort of unknown people yeah
people I mean so it's like tell me the
candidates who you know to be hardcore
laughs well here's the reason I'm asking
you that if if the argument is that
these far lefties are gonna win well
then there's no reason to have a
reformation of the Democratic Party
they're gonna go all right Greg Zia you
know our far left is one if the
Republicans win and then that sort of
far left thing implodes then there's a
huge amount of space for you why if
you're if what you're saying is there is
this huge groundswell of people that
nobody's heard of who are more moderate
sort of blue dog they're rejecting some
of this socialism stuff that's that's a
hopeful story there that I haven't heard
too much of yeah well I'm more sanguine
about this because I feel like just like
we talked about people dismissing Jordan
cuz they read a New York Times profile
or like whatever the hit pieces of the
guy who talked about him romancing the
Savage like there's horrible stuff
that's out there mmm-hmm
but they haven't actually read his book
or they haven't seen an actual lecture
or they haven't read an opposing piece
even if you only want to read profile so
it's like maybe read a flattering one
yeah if you hold yourself to be any
intellectual before dismissing him is
the pseudoscientist which is absolutely
absurd in his academic record like maybe
take a more a bigger position same thing
is happening in some ways with politics
and like I don't ever want to put people
on the spot but it's like you know I
always feel like named a bunch of
congressional candidates and people are
like Acacio and across the oh yeah
people that that's not what we're
reading that's not the water we're
swimming in yeah and so to really have a
conversation we have to go outside of
the profiles about
you know you being an all writer and
Jordan being whatever Jordan is this
week it's amazing the things he's it's
incredible and you know we need to go
out and dig into that and that's a thing
where I can stab spent you know at this
point hundreds of hours with the party
and finding and I don't know all this
stuff like I'm not a natural politician
but I'm going to talk to people to go
here's what I think we need to sort of
unify the party you know under the
values that I think that we've had in
the past and need to improve on in the
future especially with anti-corruption
and here's the way that we need to talk
about issues that it did
that concede that the other side is
human and that we don't have a magical
ball to judge them and to judge all of
their moral shortcomings and what I'm
finding again and again and again and
again is that these candidates are
amazing but there's sort of no reason
unless you really go digging that you
would have heard of them because no
one's doing that and that's part of why
I you know I called you to enlist you in
my evil project yeah and I was like look
you and I agree on almost everything
yeah let me get some people on here to
talk to you so that you can see that
that's that's in fact like 90 percent of
the party well that's the thing I don't
care how this story ends as long as I
remain true to myself so if if you
succeed right and the messaging of this
succeeds and five years from now I'm
proud to be a Democrat again if that
even matters in the labeling process or
whether I'm wherever else I am as long
as I'm true to myself that's what I care
about but like like man get to it and
make this thing work and that that would
be great well I should also make make
abundantly clear like I don't mean in
any way to imply that I'm somehow like
the magical steering no no I got you I
mean you yeah but I mean that's what I'm
trying to do so I'm doing my part of
that but obviously there's a lot of
political leadership there's a lot of
people working on it my team is you know
includes Marshall Hershkovitz in Callie
Khouri like we have a lot of people who
are engaged in this so but I mean your
point holds I just realized I don't I
don't want to sit here and pretend like
I'm the unique messenger of the party
but I've been putting in a lot of time
and I think I see things in a way I have
a pretty broad range of friends and
associates and I think I can really see
things well from different perspectives
like if there if there is you know
another talent that I would claim
besides typing you know it might be that
that like I'm I'm glad and empowered to
have conversations with people like you
where you're where you have concerns
that are different than mine and a real
genuine curiosity to kind of go what're
poke all poke holes in this here's what
I'm thinking tell me everything that's
dumb because that'll give me a big
benefit when I have to go sell it
internally and certainly when we go out
in the real world because then you're
naked yeah so if I can't enlist people
who think differently and see the world
differently to really beat up ideas that
I might have it's like that's just silly
that's like wandering out
into the mob naked you know so I'm
that's just something that's always
intrigued me yeah
that's a pretty solid end point all
right I think unless you got something
better than that but that was said that
we kind of wrapped it nicely there yeah
but before I deter it into inarticulate
Nessman we'll just we'll call it a day
all right we're gonna do more on comic
books next time I think we should do all
comic bro we should you don't leak out
yeah you'll have like three viewers like
your podcast all will get super yeah
well maybe you'll get a whole bunch of
other yeah you just shift audiences a
little it's true yes all the people who
we associate with they're not going to
be interested that that's all right
it's been a pleasure man for more on
Greg follow him on the Twitter it's Greg
- jeez Hurwitz
[Music]